my name is marcell tama i'm from the
swiss tropical and papa
Deut in Basel Switzerland and I'm also
professor of epidemiology medical
parasitology and Public Health's at the
University of Basel as well as president
of the Swiss Academy of Sciences today
we would like to talk a little bit about
how we reach elimination of malaria by
looking on what information we have to
collect and how we have to use this
information swiftly in order to cut
transmission means eliminate malaria in
the different parts of the world
therefore our learning objectives are to
start with how we are monitoring and
evaluate our malaria control and
elimination programs but how we also do
more specifically out of this classic
Lemony malaria surveillance we would
like to explain a little bit on the
different strategies of malaria
monitoring and evaluation and how we
reach out of these concepts really to
surveillance
response approaches and we then
understand how this arranged response
approaches are not only theoretically
propagated but really put into a
specific endemic setting in order to
serve our programs of malaria
elimination and how at the end these
parts of surveillance and response are
part of the overall public health
response in our malaria elimination and
finally eradication programs we will
have the strategies for serines
elimination in different settings that
we look at and then we IND have an
in-depth look on the data collection and
on how we make decisions out of this
data that we collect and how we actually
move from collecting data monitoring and
evaluation to it's really so veins
response approaches as well as we will
look at specific case studies that have
used this approach successfully to reach
malaria elimination and of course the
name is to understand that vistas
servants responds approaches we not only
achieve elimination but also we really
tackle the problem where it is worse and
where we actually look for the best
equitable approaches in reaching
elimination the first part will be
really to look at strategies for
surveillance systems in different
elimination settings the basis of this
is that we have in our population in any
malaria endemic area three types of
populations we have two not infected a
symptomatic people we have two infected
asymptomatic people and we have the
infected symptomatic people and for each
of the three population groups we have
to do the same thing we have actually to
see that the not infected asymptomatic
do not get infected we have to see that
the infected asymptomatic s' cannot
continue transmitted so that means we
treat them so that their reservoir of
the infection is eliminated and we have
two infected symptomatic people where
the goal is that first of all they are
not getting sick or if they are sick
they actually are cured and we also
prevent that they further transmitted to
the mosquitoes and if we do these to all
the three population groups then we can
achieve the interruption of transmission
and that's the aim elimination means
interruption of transmission it does not
just mean reducing of morbidity and in
order to reach eradication
you must actually bring three building
blocks together first of all you have to
detect all the people who have parasites
the reservoir secondly you have to cure
the peoples you have to eliminate the
reservoir and of course you have to
prevent that any parasites are taken up
by the mosquitoes and it's only if these
three building blocks are put together
we can achieve elimination and
eradication the key issue on this whole
thing is that it occurs concurrently you
cannot do a little bit of detection a
little bit of cure and a little bit of
prevention of transmission you must do
these three things together in a given
endemic area in a given transmission
pocket surveillance is key in order to
detect the parasite the range is key in
order to take people who carry the
parasite or could transmit malaria and
here is a graph from the malaria port of
2015 already and where it said actually
that surveillance systems are
unfortunately weakest where the highest
burden is there and we just take this as
a reminder to say that where
surveillance is not functioning our
control and elimination efforts are not
functioning that's the take-home message
and after having not just published this
information but how w-h-o is published a
new version of the surveillance manual
the surveillance manual is not just a
book with recipes it just emphasizes how
important it is to really detect
parasites to understand what the
transmission pocket is in order to
really act as we said simultaneously on
asymptomatic and symptomatic people in
order to cut transmission this has been
launched in 2012 and unfortunately we
must say today this message of having
rigorous surveillance and having
followed it by a adequate Public Health
response is still not translated into
action in many many places